and I went to go look and I had a dent
right in my hair for two years and I'm
here to take us a horror story so the
department that I was the news and
returns we have this main policy where
it's 365 days a year you can return
anything you want and turn the entire
store if you want to okay usually a
normal day in IKEA is like when people
you just expect to get their money back
even without a receipt and that's how
the story just be arising because I
can't give you something that I don't
have proof for baby it's just what
anywho a gentleman came over to my
express lane and he wanted to return his
mattress you can return your mattress if
it is covered it has this plastic still
on it for your money back that you pay
for you like with the credit card debit
card cash money whatever you used if he
did not then it's open then we have to
give you a store credit for the item so
the gentleman came over to my express
lane and he had his mattress on the cart
it was open but it was still like in
good condition the gentleman came to me
and he was like I want to return return
now it was like a receipt with you know
no receipt returned now you know okay
sir try all that I can I'm sorry how
about we go to our portal so we have
this portal we can look at your receipts
for within two years back after two
years we can't go any further so then I
was looking first receipt could not find
it my man just came over like hating so
just give it to him okay cool yeah yeah
sure or not and then I told him I can
get him store credit for the item
instead and he went off because I don't
want store credit give me cash now I was
like sir I'm sorry can I do that for you
if you can find your receipt like maybe
we can like work something out with our
managers but I just can't
he's like no no no no no where's your
magic hit the table his manager came
over took some exact thing that I told
him he was like this is so stupid and I
was like I can only get so much so any
who's they conflicted everything with
each other and their manager left and
before I can even give him his refund we
have to give you a plastic slate not to
put the mattress inside of it this man
go play his damn matches on my counter
he hit my computer and it went crashing
another thing keep in mind I have my
hair in a flat top it was like oh you
know kid in place power or whatever as
he was putting it on he hit me upside my
head oh they just kid to punch was like
I can't
I'm not my adrenaline was rushing anywho
so I like walked away and then he left
after I was done we had like this mirror
in the back of our spare parts
department and I went to go look and I
had a dent right in my hair pretty much
hi my name is Jonathan I've worked at
IKEA for 11 months now and I'm gonna
tell you a horror story alright so it
was a normal regular average day at IKEA
in the returns department said no one
ever
so I'm a first customer comes up the
couple they're really nice hi you know
we did a whole kitchen order and one of
our cabinets is the wrong size so we
need to return it absolutely I can do
the return for you but I'm going to
order another size yes we already know
the measurements okay great I can return
it to store credit for you and then you
can apply it that way you don't have to
wait for your refund your money to come
back so start the return do you have
your receipt perfect type everything in
I remember that they said that they
already knew the size that they want it
so I said I'll go ahead and create a new
order for you so you don't have to go
back into the store go upstairs go to
the kitchen department trying to be nice
trying to save them time it's like so
you just need the cabinet right yeah
yeah we just need the cabinet oh right
yeah we aren't gonna need the cabinet
door in a different size as well oh we
had a drawer in it as well
yeah oh right we do need the drawer
front we need the shelves we need to
show I don't know if you've ever like
shopped at IKEA but everything is aa la
carte everything so I'm basically
building this kitchen cabinet from
scratch piece by piece the orders
created and so I just go through
everything each item one by one I'm like
okay so I have this in this size they're
like yes I have this in this size yes at
this point it's been like maybe 40
minutes so if you ever go to Ikea and
you make a return and you're wondering
why you're waiting so long this is why
review the order everything's perfect
they signed off on everything all the
sizes everything's correct I go to print
look at my screen the orders gone
disappeared doesn't exist like it never
happened but it did happen cuz I just
spent 45 minutes on it I was there I was
asking the questions piece by piece the
frame the door the drawer the door front
and the shells the whole thing so in my
mind I'm thinking to myself oh my god
what do I do like there's no way I can
recreate this order
that's another 45 minutes I'm gonna miss
my break I everyone's staring at me
there were only like five customers in
line now there are 25 customers because
I decided to go like above and beyond
and give good customer service I felt
like the weight of Ikea and all of
Sweden was on my shoulders I was like
okay what I'll do
trying to be smart I was like okay I'll
create another order and then try to go
back like three or four order numbers to
see you know if the orders are in
numerical order spoiler alert they're
not so there I am I spent like 45
minutes trying to be nice
trying to help these customers trying to
save them time and guess what they had
to go upstairs through the store back to
the kitchens and do the whole thing over
I was so embarrassed I felt so sad they
like lost efficient me and it was like
so do you still want it on store credit
they were like nope we want to back to
the card I was like yep mm-hmm
understandable yep got it yep you'll be
getting full refund so sorry and that's
what you get when you go above and
beyond for a customer service hi I'm
Tyler I worked at IKEA for one year and
I'm about to tell you a horror story
so normally at IKEA I'm in customer
service so I work the cash registers and
assisting with customer service summer
sale weekend five items or less
I'm checking items normal day old ladies
got some candles
I'll take those candles for ya start to
hear a ruckus in the back of the line
it's pretty far back nothing too crazy
still scan to scan in those candles the
ruckus is being caused by a man in a
wheelchair and a woman in a scooter and
one of them cut in front of the other
person and they are very upset as I'm
scanning the candles I'm thinking go to
a different Lane please go to a
different Lane maybe you forgot
something go to a different Lane do not
stay in this Lane I realized that I'm
going to have to do something besides
and candles I step out I go back there
try to defuse the situation I'm not
great at conflict resolution I tell them
hey can he not do this that did not work
that made it worse I would call security
but I'm pretty new at this point so I
don't know the security jumper probably
sure to learn that did not no one is
there to help I'm scanning as quick as I
can to get these people through the line
there is now talk of violence I'm not
sure how maybe running over each other's
toes I tell them look here's what's
gonna happen I'm gonna scan your items
and I'm gonna scan your items I'm gonna
scan them as fast as I possibly can so
that we can get this over with
they're still mad about that also mad
about the order I chose luckily someone
caught wind of the trouble security is
now called
and hanging out behind me just waiting
so that they can be escorted out I scan
the items it is successful they are
still upset but not at me anymore there
was a fight in the parking lot that day
but I don't know if it was them it could
have been a completely separate fight
not confirmed
that's rumor that's why thank you
[Music]
[Music]